most people fear it being tough when
they're asking for something crazy do
you know how hard it is to be a
millionaire gonna be hard and that's
okay like it's okay that it sucks in the
beginning it's okay that you're not
making money at the beginning if the
thing that people think about becoming
great about doing the extraordinary is
that it's just meant for some people and
not meant for others rise and shine it's
an spresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message
respect your ambitions over to you Gary
Vaynerchuk also if you want to know our
Gary Vee and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below patience and
failure they all ladder up to one thing
which is insecurity I think most people
fear it being tough when they're asking
for something crazy do you know how hard
it is to be a millionaire it's it's
unbelievably hard 99% of people in the
world never even remotely get close
number one biggest mistake all of you
make is you don't realize it's gonna
take 21 years for success
twenty-one years ago now look most
people don't understand what it is to do
a million
everybody thinks everyone should do a
million a million a million I laugh at a
million 99% of the people watching this
video right now for 31 years from now
because everything will be online will
never taste a million 99% of you now
when you internalize that all of a
sudden now you're gonna respect what
you're asking yeah I want people to
respect their audacious ambitions more
most entrepreneurs dream big and go home
you've got massive goals and an
unrealistic timeline then when you don't
achieve your goals do end up feeling
like a failure and shutting down your
business the truth is building a
business is gonna take way longer than
you think it will and until you
understand that until you feel that and
appreciate that
you're living in a fantasy land and will
likely quit on your genius idea too soon
before you end up making money with it
so in my first business I thought I was
gonna you know be rich overnight amazing
not quite overnight but I thought I was
gonna make money pretty quickly I turned
down six-figure jobs I'd be traveling
around the world to go and do what I
thought was my dream job to do this
business by making $300 a month but I
thought well that's not gonna last like
tuna bucks a month well we'll start
cranking it out soon I'm imagine if
we're doing this full-time we're we're
doing this part-time and having some
little success but if I put full-time
hours into it then it's gonna really
take off and it didn't take off it took
a long time to get going and that really
took a beating on my self-confidence it
didn't help that I was too embarrassed
and ashamed to tell my friends about
what I was going through but I felt
worthless I felt like I should have
figured it out sooner I felt like other
entrepreneurs were crushing it and Here
I was sucking and unable don't have
success and I got to the point where I
told my business partner that I quit
I remember one meal family meal
Thanksgiving or something where I told
my business partner I called him on the
phone and said that I quit like I need
to feel like I'm a worth worthwhile
human being you know I need to feel like
I have some kind of value as a person
because my soul is being sucked out of
me in this business I feel worthless and
we're not getting the results I'm
putting in the work if I wasn't putting
in the work that's one thing but I'm
putting in the work I'm putting in
effort I'm trying here I'm really trying
here
and we're getting nothing $300 a month
it sucks and I could have quit on that
business I told my partner that I quit
and then I got up the next day and
realized I don't want to quit I can't
quit too soon on this I would regret
quitting without having given absolutely
everything and that's when I discovered
the idea of Milan success I asked myself
who else had built the business before
in this space and what could I learn
from them and apply it to my company
where I discovered Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that ended up
saving the company but I almost quit you
know I almost I almost kept to that quit
decision and my partner could have
helped me to it and said the next day he
opened the door and just looked me in
the eye and and I just walked in we
didn't we didn't talk about it you know
to his credit he didn't say well I
thought you quit why are you showing
back up here I almost quit I almost quit
on that path and I'm now I'd likely be
in some corporate job that I hate and I
think that happens to too many people
you think it's gonna be easier than it
is and then you get dissatisfied you you
get upset with yourself you beat
yourself down too much because other
people have had tons of success why are
you not having that as well and so
that's what I want to try to combat I
want you to realize it's gonna be hard
and that's okay
like it's okay that it sucks at the
beginning it's okay that you're not
making money at the beginning if it goes
faster than expected that's amazing but
to think that in six months your
business is gonna explode and you're
gonna be a millionaire kind of like what
I thought then you're setting yourself
up for failure
if you look at most most not all some
success stories do happen overnight but
most success stories are not an
overnight success we just think they are
and that's a really dangerous
proposition because it means that you
could likely quit on a genius idea
something that could really have a huge
impact and make you rich beyond your
wildest dreams like you could be
quitting on that it's still possible
that that thing could come true you're
just not giving it enough time because
you think it should be easier so I'm
gonna give you three steps you can
follow that will help make sure that you
don't quit on a great idea and you can
stay strong and stick at it rule number
one is model success and this is the
thing that saved my company right
modeling Bill Gates understanding how he
built Microsoft not from however much
money he makes now but zero to one like
how did it go from zero to one how do
you make your first million that's what
I
to do and it was through partnerships
for him and so I said okay find somebody
else who sell into my target audience
and make a partnership like Microsoft
made partnerships in his industry and
within a couple weeks I had my first
check for thirteen and a half thousand
dollars I've applying this strategy and
it was it was months and months and
months of making $300 a month and now I
was I was making I had 13 a half
thousand dollar check are you kidding me
that was that was gold like that doesn't
seem like a huge amount now but man that
was life-changing for me and more
important than that I had a model that I
could continue to follow that was only
the first check that we got and I could
replicate that across and so ever since
that moment when I was 20-something
years old early 20s model and success
has been the thing it's been the thing
that it saved me it saved my business
and it's why I created this YouTube
channel too I wanted to continue to
model success is why I keep showing all
these successful people from different
backgrounds and what we can learn from
them so whenever you don't know what to
do or wherever you feel like you want to
quit model and success does two things
one it gives you hope because chances
are the people who you're profiling or
reading about that came from something
worse than what you're going through
right now
they grew up in an environment or
background worse than where you are
right now and so that gives hope like if
they could do it from a worse upbringing
then I can do it too with all the
resources that I have and then to gives
you specific ideas so this is
specifically exactly what Bill Gates did
to build Microsoft ok I'm gonna copy
that for myself how can I copy that
exact strategy and apply to my business
and it won't 100% work but 90% works and
that last 10% I need to tweak for my
business and so model success find the
people who won you look up to who are in
your industry who you can learn from but
also just in general people that you
look up to because if you're in software
and you love Oprah you can still learn
from her and apply it to make your
business better so number one model
success
number two is focus on momentum one of
the big reasons why people quit and they
give up and they lose self-esteem and
lose their values because they want to
be up here which is amazing great to
have that great big ambitious goal and
you're only here but your your your
building slowly and it's that focusing
on momentum that actually makes a
difference it's not how close are you
yet to your big goal but
much better you than you were yesterday
at the beginning when you have no
revenue and you made no money yesterday
and no manna day before and then when in
the week before the money may not be the
metric that you follow but you might be
measuring how many people are using your
thing or how many inquiries you're
getting or how many hits you're getting
on your YouTube videos or whatever other
metric that you can track to show that
there's something happening in your
business right there is some positive
momentum forward and keep focusing on
that what I love doing as an
entrepreneur and still of finding one
thing that works
I'll keep testing testing testing
testing testing testing testing I find
one thing that works and I'm boom all-in
massively focused on making that thing
happened so on a macro scale you look at
YouTube I was testing a whole bunch of
different things and then I tried
YouTube and I liked it and started
working boom we're going we're going
all-in on YouTube let's go three videos
a day let's go five four and a half
years ago I had seven thousand
subscribers now 1.6 million let's go
right I want to get to eight videos a
day let's go let's go let's go like it's
the moment now's the time blinders on
let's go make it happen don't get
distracted by all the other
opportunities around you we got stuff to
do what a life to make happen right like
let's go let's go let's go right that's
how I think and then with even within
the micro of YouTube I test this series
it doesn't work just this series okay
it's okay this test sister's hit up on
the top ten people love this let's go
right from one top 10 as a test to top
10 every single day right five days a
week five days a week top 10s let's go
let's go let's go let's go when you find
the thing that works you plow it through
until it doesn't work anymore focus on
momentum not just on the results if
you're building momentum it will lead to
results but it also makes you feel good
like something's working I'm actually
getting some kind of momentum some kind
of feedback something something
something positive is happening right
and so focus on momentum will help give
you the motivation and the energy to
keep going and step number three is
don't isolate yourself I think one of
the biggest reasons why entrepreneurs
quit is because they have nobody to talk
to they don't know what's normal and
what's not normal and they just feel
really isolated alone and ends up
getting a lot worse for some people than
just quitting their business so don't
isolate yourself try to be around other
entrepreneurs try to get out of the
house or out of the condo out of the
garage and go meet other aren't you
whether that is going to meetups locally
in your in your town in your city going
to different events that are
entrepreneur related looking for
networking opportunities looking for
mastermind groups or forming your own
mastermind group ideally its face to
face but worst case just go online like
join believe nation leave a comment look
at other people's channels and get
involved just just be around other
people who are also going off and
chasing their ambitions and their dreams
and somebody who can say I you know I'm
losing hope or I'm not sure what to do
or I'm struggling right now who can also
give you feedback base of their being in
it to not just your friends and family
who think who some of them may think
you're crazy and others may just think I
love this person but I don't know what
to do to support them and help them
there's a difference when somebody who
is in it who understands it who feels
the same obsession for chasing down
their dreams and goals but haven't hit
their stride yet and they're working
towards making it better there's a
there's a camaraderie that you can get
when you're working with similar kinds
of people so don't isolate yourself like
spend time make sure there's something
in your calendar every month at least
where you're getting out of the house
and you're meeting other entrepreneurs
again whether that's a meet-up
a networking event a mastermind group
some event that's coming to town in your
city something that every month you're
out of the house you're meeting people
just to build that sense of you're not
alone that other people going through
this to some people to bounce ideas off
of and remove that isolation from your
life so those are three suggestions that
can help you the central theme still
comes down to this is a big idea that
you have and will take time for it to be
realized and it's amazing if it happens
faster than you expect but chances are
it's gonna take a lot longer than you
think if you look at any of the success
stories that people you look up to
it took them a lot longer and my biggest
fear is that you're gonna quit on your
idea way too soon that you actually have
something great that you actually are a
genius and you've got something that
could actually work but it's not working
yet and it's taking longer way longer
than you thought it would and you quit
and you move on to something else but
that could have actually been the thing
that could not just make you rich but
have a huge impact on the world and so
the point of this video is just to make
sure you understand this and take a long
time and that's okay and apply some of
those technique
to help you get through it cope with it
and go off and build something amazing
now I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question today I want to
know whose success story can you model
and apply leave it in comments below I'm
curious to find out
as Henry Rollins said I don't have
talent so I just get up earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary as a way to let
themselves off the hook because if
somebody has just gifted if they were
blessed by God if they were touched by
an angel and they just have something
that you don't and something that you
never will have then it's fine for them
to be great and you to be ordinary but
the reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate natural
talent that if somebody is graced by God
that if they have something divine about
them that they're somehow better that
it's more beautiful than the scrappy
person who's had to work for everything
they've ever had
the guy who simply acknowledges like
Henry Rollins that he doesn't have more
talent than the next person he's simply
willing to help work them he's willing
to set the alarm to get up to do
whatever it takes to find his path to
create that skill to outwork talent to
show that by putting in that energy and
that effort there's a magnification
effect that is far greater than anything
that could be given to you bestowed upon
you you have to grab it you have to take
it you have to have a level of intensity
in your life to be able to leverage it
and create something amazing and as
Warren Buffett said intensity is the
price of excellence if you want to be
great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
what you were given where you started or
even where you
going it is entirely about what you
plant at the center of your soul how
hard you're willing to go after
something how much focus you're willing
to put in your life and how often you
come back to that level of intensity for
who you want to be because if you want
to be excellent you will have to pay a
price and that price is eternal
vigilance vigilance over how you spend
your time vigilance over the demands you
make of yourself vigilance over what you
allow yourself to think and believe and
when you get to the point that you only
allow yourself to think and believe
things that move you towards your goals
that everyday the actions you take are
things that are designed to get you
there and that you have the intensity to
follow that through to shape yourself to
create a new version of you capable of
doing something extraordinary then your
life is gonna be what you want but not
until then it's never gonna be anything
if you just make other people
extraordinary and say I could never do
that
the reality is you could and you're just
not so the thing you have to face right
now is that it is within your grasp you
just have to go after it
but let me give you the one once equals
one words volume you have the most
important word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
if you want more Gary Vaynerchuk Chuck
at the top 50 rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there dwelling
on what you up on is the quickest way
for the next thing not to work